The Voice alum Christina Grimmie dead at  22 ET can confirm that the singer was  killed during a shooting in Orlando  Florida after performing at a concert at  the Plaza live we're in Orlando today  flees from the show if you live near the  Orlando Police Department told et  Christina was signing autographs  following the show when the suspect  walked up and opened fire the  unidentified person was tackled by  Christina's brother the suspect later  shot himself during the struggle and  Christina was rushed to the hospital in  critical condition  the young starlets rep released a  statement after the emergency quote it  is with a heavy heart that we can  confirm that Christina has passed we  asked at this time that you respect the  privacy of her family and her friends in  their time of mourning  a preliminary investigation is underway  according to police